for weeks now
violence in haiti's capital has been out
of control
gangs are now said to be in charge of
entire areas of port-au-prince
on tuesday at least 15 civilians were
killed when the police allegedly
responded to an attack
that had left an officer dead local
residents are in shock
i heard this terrible news i told my mom
i'll go see if any relatives died in the
massacre
i was shocked to see my cousin died for
nothing i asked myself
where this country is going among the
dead were journalists
diego charles and activist antoinette
duclear
many theories fellow activist ralph
francois says
they were executed for speaking out
against the government
she was an activist and she was very she
had a very strong message against
the government about the whole situation
actually
so we believed it was targeted and me
personally i believe like the whole
uh all other people that were you know
killed
with that was uh a plan to cover
um the target assets assassination
for months thousands of haitians have
been taken to the streets to protest
against the government of president
jovenel moise
who has ruled by decree for the past 18
months
he has failed to call for legislative
elections and wants to reform the
constitution critics say
it's an effort to strengthen his group
on power
separately gangs are claiming they're in
control of the island nation
and the government appears to be unable
or unwilling to do anything about the
security situation
last week former police officer turned
gang leader jimmy cherisier says
he was launching a revolution against
the country's elite
i am telling people to keep looking for
what belongs to them it is your money
which
is in banks stores and supermarkets so
go and get what is rightfully yours
many people have accused members of
moy's cabinet of colluding with the gang
members
in the united states some members of
congress are trying to push president
joe biden to halt u.s support for moise
and listen more to the haitian people
something
many in haiti are calling for we just
part of a whole geopolitical game
where we are not human you are just
transactions stop
pushing your velmo is when you know even
for your country you would not take this
guy
as a person would you know do something
for you
so why you continue to support
bad politicians for this country
activists say
that those who dare speak up about the
situation in the country
face intimidation and even death the
government for its part
seems unable to come up with any
solutions that will improve
people's lives teresa